no but you've changed that cycle no for
sure yes people say that they say that
that history repeats itself right cycle
perpetuates but yeah it's bollocks
absolute bollocks you know if you know
well my dad was an alcoholic and I and
that's one of the prime reasons why hmm
I want to be sober is because if I ever
have kids
romantic romantic ever want kids you
know I wanna give them an experience
that's a little different for someone
like who's grown up in as much violence
as you have yeah you're a really tender
guy yeah and for someone who has
murderous family members yeah yeah I
think that I'm a pretty tender yeah
tender person as well yeah we came out
of it all of us I think pretty unscathed
and you know I you know I think it's
society too though I think our society I
mean you know I mean I know that the me
to movement and there's certain words
that are forbidden you can't say digit
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can't say just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you get offended now
listen of course I'm my dad is six foot
six yeah but his best friend is a [ __ ]
yeah they're like [ __ ] celebrities on
the UFC circuit Wow Park up at the bar
and everyone knows him this means dad
and his best mate little Mick yeah
that's what he calls himself an
Instagram little Mick yeah he does get
offended by it I know and he's like
because he's [ __ ] cool right if
you're looking to be offended of course
you can be offended by anything yeah
generally you know people might use an
ignorant ignorant term but they're not
trying to be offensive yeah yeah you're
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's looking to be
offended right been offended 20 times in
here tonight if I wanted to be oh this
is ridiculous I came up here by myself
and [ __ ] Bobby Lee was talking [ __ ]
I'd be a [ __ ] [ __ ] wouldn't that
right and all these little pricks and
these [ __ ] little yeah the world's
gone crazy and I can't stand it cuz I
don't fit in here it's crazy how that's
something that's recreational now that's
peep those are people's hobbies to look
for things like that right it's it's
getting out of control even for me if I
if I see it Oh
an older white guy from the south right
who's raised a certain way he's allowed
a certain racism yeah I get up give him
allowance Yeah right
so if he does like an Asian accent just
to calm the detention right if it's a
millennial now yeah it's a fit a 20 year
old kid now you should know better right
but you have to put things into context
I think yeah well I guess it depends
whether from as well certainly a 20 year
old kid in in LA or New York yeah yeah
yeah 20 year old kid in [ __ ] Alaska
[Music]
did you know that you're not allowed to
say you you have to : anyway you can't
seem Eskimo that's it Eskimo you can't
say Eskimo anymore
really yeah I'm never gonna stop saying
if you have a problem yeah yeah I'm 39
years old you've always been a [ __ ]
Eskimo to me never gonna go to Eskimo
lon Wow miss cuman's yeah
wait like it no offense when you [ __ ]
asked me to show you [ __ ] great
people and I'll give you a little nose
kisses yeah but you still [ __ ] ask
you mine oh my god I know
sorry Inuits I know there Inuits no
[ __ ] eejit right yeah but it's like
um but let's suppose let's say let's
suppose this is an interesting thing
right let's say let's suppose you know
[ __ ] you know I mean people are still
using people use [ __ ] in the 60s 50s 60s
right 70s and they still use it and they
still had that justification like you
know why I said [ __ ] in the 60s you know
do people still say that I know that
have you to say there's not a term that
I hear ya sure yeah just live bla people
might say the n-word you know yeah
yeah but-but-but I don't think that
[ __ ] is a derogatory thing I guess
it's I mean if you're on the receiving
end of it it depends how it's said as
well you know it depends how they say
right right like the term you know it's
not a word you can use out here in
America [ __ ] right
don't say that love that word all the
time
yeah there's two ways of saying it you
know you can't you know that's and you
say see you when you love you can and
that's like oh my mate he's a good con
or whatever if you say [ __ ] and you
pronounce the tea parties excuse me
call me [ __ ] [ __ ] right you know and
then it's two different things you know
so it's how you say it yeah
[Music]